now an ongoing volcanic eruption on the
spanish island of la palma has
intensified firefighters were ordered to
retreat as a new vent opened up in the
side of the volcano throwing more lava
and ash into the air residents of three
more towns have been evacuated the lab
has already swallowed up hundreds of
homes and there are fears it might claim
many more
life on la palma has been upended by the
most powerful volcanic eruption in 50
years
antonio britto is a banana farmer whose
crops have been destroyed by the
volcano's ash
i had to hide my tears from my
granddaughters
i didn't want them to be scared
he is thankful that his home at least
has not been destroyed
the same cannot be said for many la
palma residents
these people are salvaging what little
they can from their homes
the island has been declared a
catastrophe zone by spain's prime
minister
we'll provide urgent housing aid for
affected residents
and also help them get everything they
need for day-to-day life
and replace the belongings they have
lost
smoke ash and rivers of molten lava
continue to pour from the volcano
burying the homes of hundreds of people
and the volcanic eruptions
are showing no signs of letting up
dw correspondent nicole aries in madrid
is following this story for us welcome
nicole what's the latest
well the latest as we just heard there
is a new eruptive map that has opened on
this volcano and there were very strong
explosions throughout the day that could
be felt through shock waves in a far
farther distance as well so quite scary
even for the scientists and there is a
lot of ashes coming down right now and
also rocks so this is why firefighters
and also other security
workers needed to retreat from certain
areas where they were doing cleanup
works and also needed to make sure that
people in this area were being safely
evacuated and these people didn't have
much time to pack up their stuff
because it was a relative that were
relative calm days before so they didn't
really expect it some of them are even
going to other islands because they have
nowhere else to go and to just give you
an idea how dense the ashes are for
example experts say that the clouds that
are being produced the ashes clouds are
as high as four kilometers and also the
lava that is uh currently running
through the landscape covering
everything under it is said to be 190
square
hectares
large this means this is around 266
football fields more or less so for
people who are on the island right now
locals this is very traumatizing they
see how their houses are being destroyed
their livelihoods are kind of ripped
away and they can that there's just
another thing going on right now they're
getting very angry at tourists and other
people who have traveled to the island
just to see this speck tackle
while their livelihoods are basically um
ripped apart in front of their eyes
right
and one of the worries is that the tip
of the volcano is might explode and
crumble um
what are the fears there what
implications would that have
well this is uh one of the scenarios
that could happen if a lot of gases and
pressure really build up this is not
it's not sure if it's very likely but
that was it would mean that it also
affects the top of the volcano and the
speed of the lava with this massive
explosion that it would cause would be
um really um as some authorities put it
unbearable a police officer who was
trying to evacuate people today actually
put it like this he says if you don't
have a safe distance when this thing
comes down it will sweep away everything
and everyone so this is one worry but at
the moment the worry is really on the
amounts of ashes and rocks coming down
and further explosions because
scientists in an interview just now on
tv said that they are still studying why
these explosions have happened they have
a few theories but they didn't want to
come forward with them as of yet
so as the situation gets worse how are
authorities responding
they're responding fairly well right
from the beginning they were always
on top of the game i mean they have been
able to evacuate everybody in time
nobody has been hurt it is material
damage that we see there's also a lot of
solidarity among islanders but also
coming from the outside
if it's donations of food or clothes or
people trying to help others to relocate
so this is um something that is going on
on the ground obviously and in a recent
development actually the local tv
station has now said that they're not
gonna show pictures of evacuees anymore
at this time and also not of the
destruction of homes because they know
how dramatic this is for the affected
and they just want to do this out of
respect for the moment okay thank you
for that dw correspondent nicole reese